joe biden
tough man he took on corn pop with the
strength of
the hero we'd expect he looked corn pop
in the eyes and said i'm sorry i called
you esther and then corn pop put away a
straight razor and then biden breathed a
sigh of relief that's kind of leadership
you need
someone who recognizes they have to
apologize and be deferential to those
who threaten them
which is why it's interesting that joe
biden was willing to apologize to corn
pop
but then called vladimir putin what do
you call him a stone cold
killer yep he's like i looked him in the
eyes and said he was a killer
and the response to this vladimir putin
was like okay uh how about we have a
debate
live and uh that's the story right now
and i think we have to talk about
whether or not i think it'll be
interesting to talk about whether or not
anyone has confidence in binding because
i just put in the title i'm like dude
biden's too weak
he's not going to be able to handle this
vladimir putin would walk all over him
and
i it pains me to say this i don't want
to speak ill of the president
compared to the russian president we got
to be honest with ourselves so we'll
talk about this we also got some other
crazy stories democrats are trying to
remove sitting members of congress
republicans
and they want to install a democrat who
lost her election
even after the republican is already
seated certified and winning
this is the power grab they're going
after kavanaugh they want to change
election laws
it's exactly what we thought was going
to happen joining us today to talk about
all this stuff we've got curt schlichter
hey introduction to stay here introduce
myself
yeah who are you what are you doing oh
i'm a guy you know i'm a raconteur
man about town you're a retired army
colonel
senior columnist for yeah i guess you
know every other person who comes hell
everybody on your show is a colonel
everybody this week uh no but you're
also a senior columnist for town hall i
am i'm the author of a number of books
including the kelly turnbull series of
conservative novels
hailed by bill crystal as appalling so
i'm
very excited about that and i write for
town hall three times a week monday
wednesday and thursday and occasionally
i go on the twitter machine
and to cause trouble well a little bit
you told me i was wrong i did i did i
was like i criticized your tweets but i
don't bring i don't want to bring up
that journalist because i don't want to
like you know what it don't want to make
a thing it's not that i don't it's that
but also
i don't like giving people like they get
a shout out from it you know what i mean
yeah so we're really not talking about
that what i think the interesting part
is
is you can say kurt you were wrong and i
can go
oh well that's interesting that's right
and we aren't in a fist fight
right right we're not rolling around in
the mud punching each other you were
like
okay each other you were like okay and
then we talked about it and right and
then we had a conversation was actually
a rather interesting one yeah and here
we are and that's kind of the point
but uh that's not like america
it wasn't fist fights it was just kind
of people were mad at each other
disregard disrespected each other but
now it's like you
literally show up to your house with
bricks well and then and canceling each
other and there's a i think we're going
to talk a little later about somebody
who got cancelled today
and she probably didn't see it coming oh
yeah definitely yeah
and this is there so there's a crack
forming in the in the woke cancel
culture it was
actually a a black woman was cancelled
for being racist against asians
which flips the whole privilege thing on
its head because agents are supposed to
be
more privileged than white people i
thought i was double-wide is there a
brochure i can consult to get the whole
hierarchy of oppression
i know all you have to do is
bend the knee to those who are woke and
just say tell me what to say
and you're safe it would be that would
make my life a lot easier if i was so
inclined to be a groveling [ __ ] i am
not so inclined
ah well now you're gonna get canceled
you know see the nice thing is if you
i watch star trek i do not watch
soundtrack i've made love to a woman
um those are fighting words
[Laughter]
uh the old star trek where you got
captain kirk and he's all you know
it's cool i was gonna he's a little he's
a little chubby we made
we can identify with that we made the
four we we
we talked about the the the four lights
meme yesterday have you ever heard
anybody anybody see anybody say that
mean yeah so captain picard is being
tortured and they're trying to force him
to say
oh i think i heard of that yeah say
there's three there's five
five but there's actually four it's just
a meme now representing people who
refuse to say the lie
how does that relate to a red pill if
you take the red pill
you say there's four yes and it and if
you want to mix the
you're either by memes so when you say
when if someone were to say there were
five lights
they're either completely blue pilled or
they're subservient to those who are
torturing them which is pretty much the
same thing
right right all right well here's my
question though could neo take on
old school captain kirk picard yeah he's
crusty and a [ __ ]
neo from the matrix neo from the matrix
versus captain kirk i think we need to
explain
another question he downloaded kung fu
was captain kirk in the matrix or have
they already
how about how about we'll get into all
this ian and hold on
you look a lot like greg kinnear i just
needed to get that out there thank you
i mean it's freaking me out i'm sitting
here air is clear all right all right
all right i'm not pounding the table
okay don't do it we got it in it yeah
that's one of our rolls don't pound the
table what up everybody ian crossland in
the house
greg kaneer coming at you boom
i am actually here but kurt is stealing
the spotlight already off the rails
i know he said mallet malice to warn you
about
he did yes it's true and we're gonna
have a great time tonight
all right before we get started i'm
talking about vladimir putin on stuff go
to timcast.com become a member here we
go
because look we we face the possibility
of censorship every single day
there's legit things we can't we there's
like names we can't say there's things
we can't say youtube will delete the
stream instantly
so we set up timcast.com in the event
you know we get purged you can find us
there
and as a member you get access to
exclusive members only posts
and yesterday we we talked about that
biden green screen
conspiracy theory i think we debunked it
you know pretty
pretty well and now we talked about that
with jack we also ended up talking about
god i guess because
for some reason this just stuff it just
happens it's pretty heavy that's why
well we have conversations then all of a
sudden it turns into conversation about
god in the universe so hey if you want
those exclusive segments
sign up we're gonna have one later with
kurt and it'll be a whole lot of fun
cause i think
you know kurt's very high energy and
probably gonna swear a lot on the
on the members only one you're allowed
to swear right oh wow yeah yeah you
have another starbuck expresso thing
that's right that's right
so also don't forget to like share
subscribe if you do like the podcast
leave us a good review give us five
stars all that good stuff
ladies and gentlemen the big news today
is that vladimir putin has challenged
joe biden to a debate a
live debate after biden called
him a killer biden spoke out about the
russian president in an abc news
interview this week abc news reports
quote i've just thought of this now
putin told a russian state television
reporter
i want to propose to president biden to
continue our discussion
but on the condition that we do it
basically live as it's called
without any delays and directly in an
open direct discussion
it seems to me that would be interesting
for the people of russia
and for the people of the united states
they say putin's invitation
seems to amount to a challenge to biden
to a live televised debate following a
day of diplomatic uproar
that began when biden said he thought
putin was a killer in an interview with
abc news's george stephanopoulos
russia recalled its ambassador to the
u.s in response
to the remark now uh i think vladimir
putin's a killer
well i think vladimir putin thinks
valencia putin's a killer
he's proud i know do you think he was
like oh man
he called me a killer can you believe
that he called he called the ambassador
home to high-five him
i mean the guy was a kgb colonel yeah
all right he's
you know he's not he's not mr rogers he
was like watching tv and then when biden
said it's like that leonardo dicaprio
meanwhile like points to the tv and then
like
you know his body his kgb buddies are
like yeah
they're like dude the president just
shouted you out and he's like oh yeah
and then now now he wants the debate
because he wants biden to say it more oh
i know
you called me killer thank you not even
that
it's like biden calling him a killer is
good for vladimir putin
it makes him look strong it makes him
look you know dangerous
you know i look i i i was old school
cold war i was literally in the cold war
in the army
and i i i learned a lot about how to
fight russians and everything i kind of
kind of don't like the russians do like
the ukrainians spend a lot of time there
yeah ukraine's cool but
ukraine is cool yeah um but uh
this russia
is not the threat it used to be it is a
threat it is not a pure competitor it's
got a lot
i i i it's like a [ __ ] with a strong
right arm
do you do you remember when uh obama
called them a regional power
you know he he they're not quite a
regional power but they're not quite
the superpower that they were because
they can't project force the way they
did they do have nuclear weapons
but look if you want a real threat it's
china and if you don't want to talk
about china you talk about anything else
yeah including russia or extremists
yeah so we've have you ever heard of
china uncensored i have not heard of
china
big youtube channel they talk about
china and things that are going on there
and they mentioned that you know when
biden was transitioning
some of the people were fairly pro-china
speaking about how it was good
that jobs were going there there was a
certain like diplomatic incident i
suppose where these guys were
deferential to china
and there's fears that as you know china
has taken hong kong already
yes they're they're imprisoning the
uyghur muslims they want taiwan
and they will take taiwan and joe biden
will not do anything to stop him
uh joe biden's gonna have a decision
point when they move on taiwan first of
all they war game it they know how to do
it and i'm not talking about anything
outside of uh open source stuff you read
this stuff anywhere
there are war games recently revealed
where
for years americans have been you know
we practice war games
and we lose against china and
china's got a lot of advantages when you
look at taiwan taiwan is very close
taiwan is very far from us we have to
put ourselves
on a few bases which are easy to hit
easy to target small concentrated areas
we also have very few ships compared to
what we used to we used to have what a
what a 600 ship navy with ronald reagan
i believe
we're now under 300. wow really yes
are there a lot of uh submarines that we
don't know about uh there is nothing
people don't know about uh you can't
like secretly build a submarine
because it's like 10 billion dollars and
they know where our submarine bases are
where we manufacture submarines so you
take satellite pictures
what if they have like a subterranean
manufacturing plant
um moving all the materials i would
notice it
i think i think it it's kind of hard to
hide a ship
you can hide submarines can hide out at
sea obviously but they have to come in
and they have to restock and refit
right right so i i mean i think we we
know the numbers the problem is the
numbers are growing for the chinese the
chinese are serious military
you don't find them uh doing a 60-day
stand down for the extremist boogie men
who don't exist look i spent 27 years in
the military okay
i didn't meet any white supremacists i
didn't meet any extremists i met people
who wanted to do their job
and well then what you're basically
telling our audience is one of two
things
either you didn't look hard enough or
you're lying to protect them because
that's the only
the only joke joe biden says okay we got
to weed out these extremists
okay so so what's going on huh which one
is it well yeah
man checkmate good point
um no it's a it's a lot easier to talk
about you know
mythical extremists they're claiming the
gadsden flag
was a sign of extremism like some guy
had on his facebook profile the gadsden
flag so he got removed from dc
you know guard duty or whatever it's the
symbol of the american revolution
like don't some states have that as
their state flag or something well maybe
maybe the american revolution is uh
going to be branded extremist
i wouldn't be surprised they already got
they got the 1619 project
claiming that the real founding of this
country was 1619.
so actually they've already said the
american revolution was racist
they've said that it was a bunch of
racist white landowners trying to
preserve their slaveocracy it's really
weird
how the beneficiaries of
all this alleged supremacy stuff are
also
the very same people promoting it
yeah it's weird because it's all
affluent uh
uh establishment types yeah and of
course the establishment has changed
it's no longer
like you know the guy who has buick
dealership in town
yeah instead it's the uh professor of
gender studies did you uh did you hear
about the elephant walk that we did in
guam
this past year um i i know we did one
and you know we were treated right oh
really we were treated because
i guess trump or somebody ordered that
we were gonna do a show of force
long story short my understanding china
sent a strike force
through this you know the strait of
taiwan or whatever and
this was a show of force the u.s
responded with what's called an elephant
walk
where we get bombers and fighters and
they start going around the runways in
guam
and then they were treated because the
u.s was advised
china could blow up that base with a
snap of a finger and our planes will be
able to get off the ground
uh it is a problem that the uh chinese
have decided to pursue an asymmetrical
offensive they look they find our
weaknesses
the thing is we have a limited number of
bases
okay on land so you just target
everything there
we have a problem they've got all of
china and they have mobile missiles
yeah so if they you know where's the
missile i don't know it's on chinese
highway one going up and down the coast
i mean i think this is this is why joe
joe biden calling out putin has been
nothing but good for putin
i think the whole russian narrative has
been nothing but good for narrat for
for for russia it projects you know
america saying russia is the greatest
threat and then they can use that
as to puff themselves up make them seem
bigger than they really are it's kind of
a sugar high
i mean because i mean they kind of know
you know that
you know mostly you know half our
population is going to die at 57
of vodka poisoning because they make it
in the radiator of a zill
truck and do they really do that or are
you just being
being a jerk i i'm being a jerk but but
you know you never know man i mean they
dude if you spend time over there i know
i
spent time in ukraine not russia i've
seen i've seen them those dudes
right yeah man you don't want to drink
the stuff that hands you into no no i
was going to say they figure stuff out
they do
and they're smart yeah when you've got
limited resources because of communism
oh yeah
they figure out how to make vodka and a
radiator oh my gosh
the the thing is we're going to see that
more here tonight the thing is
working overseas and i worked overseas
in kosovo among
primarily among the albanians and these
guys they they were just no
law they were they were smuggling and
scamming
because they had had to for a thousand
years other people had conquered them
and oppressed them so there was no law
and order
right these are not guys who stop at the
stop sign at 3 a.m in the morning when
they're out driving
americans will because we're used to law
and order we're used to well
if i if somebody breaches a contract
i'll go to court and my contract will
get enforced
if somebody hits me with a bat a cop
will arrest
them we can't take that to grant for
granted so we act as if
there's law russians never did that
because there wasn't it was all
arbitrary
yeah the albanians didn't in kosovo
until we started putting things into
place there
and i think that's one of the things
we're losing here
as people lose the ability to appeal
to institutions to protect them whether
it's department of justice
uh you know the news media remember the
news media
should be out there saying hey look at
these towns ruined
because you know jobs are getting
shipped off to china but they won't do
that
because that makes democrats look bad
do you see what glenn greenwald tweeted
recently let me see if i can find this
because we're going to rag on the media
now about journalism oh yeah glenn
greenwald tweeted give me more
if you think the real power centers in
the u.s are the proud boys
4chan and boogaloos rather than the cia
fbi nsa wall street and silicon valley
and spend most of your time
battling the former while serving the
latter as stenographers your
journalism is definitely ish
accurate yeah how will swear so adult
family friendly right how weird is it
that a
hardcore conservative like me is saying
yeah glenn griego
got a good point i mean this guy is not
a conservative like i
am definitely not he's progressive no
but we but
you know i i think we have a common
framework
where we want institutions that function
you know we we've been talking about
this a little bit we've talked about it
before moral frameworks
and we were talking about how the united
states is founded upon a judeo-christian
moral framework yes
whether or not secular individuals
realize it or not when they say
things like i don't get my morals from
the bible you actually do
like you were raised in a culture that
valued certain things free speech
yes classical liberalism if you grew up
in china you'd have a different set of
beliefs if you grew up in india if you
grew up in pakistan the people there
have a different culture and different
set of beliefs
you didn't naturally come to the ideas
of classical liberalism
it actually took a very long time and
the american revolution was proof of
that
i bring that up because what i think
we're seeing is
why is it a staunch conservative like
yourself is sitting here going like
lying green world is correct
well it's because your moral framework
is based on the same similar ideas true
or mostly the same while you disagree on
a ton of policy and political ideas
exactly
you come from a similar root moral
framework these these these
woke leftists and all these democrats
have a completely different moral
framework
exactly they have they have completely
rejected it and that is one of the
reasons our institutions are collapsing
their generation i call it uh cultural
trust fund babies
right none of these guys built these
institutions the institutions
all really came into being before or
after world war ii you look at
look at academia right you know a call
they haven't changed that much you look
at college today the way they teach in a
college the way they taught in 1946
yeah you got some video and stuff now
but essentially it's some guy standing
in the front of the room in front of a
bunch of hungover students
you know yapping at them all our
institutions from the news media
to the to the department of justice
academia
uh even the nfl they're all tired and
exhausted and they are run by
the cultural trust fund babies look at
the kennedys
you know john f kennedy kind of a
dynamic guy
third generation kennedys they're at a
crack house
i mean that and that's who are these
guys who run
things you know they haven't achieved
anything they didn't build it except the
tech guys
they kind of did so that's a little
different but other than tech
all the institutions are run by people
who didn't build them didn't create them
and are frankly unworthy they're just
inheritors they say they got a
credential
they say generational wealth only lasts
three generations
bingo you've got the first generation
that earns it yep the children who saw
their their
you know parents working and then the
grandkids who have no idea
and just got money and lived with it
bingo and they are
squandering that inheritance now they
you know these guys they think that this
whole american thing where they live
prosperous and safe
is like the natural state of being dude
get out
more okay you've been to the favelas and
i hope i pronounce that right brazil
yeah i've been to complexo do ala mao
yeah the biggest favela
yes not not a lot like america it's
getting better
but you're right but but it's a very
they they're very different stay in
nature
they pacified them that's what it was
called when the it was the i think it
was the
was it the bopy or it might have been
the kore there's these two different
like
swat groups they went in with big guns
and they killed everybody who got in the
way exactly yeah
the thing is they they because they
didn't build it
because they didn't suffer to create it
they didn't earn it they're squandering
it
and they think it's always going to be
there for them
but if things degenerate to the natural
state of man which is power
i think they've got a problem no
definitely because the a lot of these
people
are not particularly well suited to a
world where life is nasty brutish and
short
they don't think it exists let me let me
tell you you know the one of the first
lessons of being a you know like a cd
hustler music hustler in the street
you you may have seen these people back
when cds were bigger they were walking
around the city
and they got a stack of cds and like yo
yo here buy my cd buy my cd
and you're like i don't know who you are
i don't know your music is why would i
buy your cd
there's a reason why they don't give the
cd away they want you to listen to their
music but they know
they give you the cd for free you're
gonna do you're gonna throw it away
throw in the trash yeah but if you give
him a buck for it now you're like i
bought this
like i'm not i don't want to finally
just kind of listen to it yeah well it's
something of value that that i had to
you know work for you give some
you get them for free and they don't
value anything you put on it's my
chemical romance and you go damn it i
wish i'd thrown it away well i don't
think my chemical
romance is going around selling cds in
the street i don't know maybe they
should
are they still a thing yes they are i
don't know oh they are literally maybe
like
really 17 years ago i don't know it's
like a crappy band you know
all right get back is easy but you know
just offend all the millions i'd rather
go with the
i'd rather go with the my chemical
romance don't they play a song that
everyone plays at prom i don't know sure
yeah i don't know i'm a replacements in
clash
so yeah well so so anyway this is it
it's a really
i think it's a really important point
because we're talking a lot about this
yesterday with depressed millennials
how they don't work they sit around all
day
and then you were mentioning something
interesting you you were saying that for
many of these people the lockdown is
like their woodstock
it is yeah and i'm gonna write about
this a town hall on monday
this is excitement look why are
dystopian novels so
and entertainment so exciting why do
people actually put up with watching the
walking dead
because it shows them what a world would
be like
that they're in but actually has
challenges
has risks human beings like excitement
look you were telling me a little
earlier about how you got
gassed by tear gas oh yeah to see i mean
let's look at objectively what kind of
lunatic goes towards a chemical irritant
i did when i was in the army i
volunteered
and then we were like okay now you gotta
go in this chemical uh
you know this little hut we're gonna
burn cs and make your eyes water we're
like no no no but secretly we're like
if i do that i'm pretty cool yeah and
you went towards it too
well so there's a reason we're trying to
document what's going on in these
conflicts so i was in brazil i've been
in a bunch of different conflicts in the
us you know riots and stuff
brazil substantially more brutal and
just the story was
in the u.s i see all of these activists
all these lefties
getting probably the lowest grade cs
smoke i've ever experienced in my life
and it's like your eyes are for kids
well the police say it's not even tear
gas oh it's just smoke don't worry but
it is an irritant it is it is tear gas
it's just the lowest grade
and i see these people like coughing and
gagging and crying and everything
when i was this stuff is nothing when i
was in brazil they used like the top
tier military grade stuff that was so
intense
like the guy i'm with has got like just
snot pouring out of his face and he's
braving through it because he's been an
actual war
his eyes are swollen i'm sitting there i
ripped my sweaty sock off shoved at my
mouth and we run through the smoke to
keep filming
the brazilian rioters they did the same
thing like these people have have seen
real hardship and real confidence oh
yeah
these american you know they're soft man
americans are soft
see that was the purpose a lot of hard
people did a lot of hard work
to allow a generation not to have to do
any of that but the problem is human
beings
it's like if you don't exercise you get
fat and lazy but
but mentally you also get kind of kind
of fat and lazy
if you're not challenged that's why you
know
people do extreme sports do
skateboarding you get screwed up
skateboarding
you can get hurt and you don't do that
because
i i mean but but you do it anyway
because it fills a need inside you and i
i i you know and i i think some of the
antifa stuff
is a little bit of that too uh of course
they want conflict
yeah but they want to prove conflict
right they know they're good
they know the charges are going to get
dropped they know the cops not going to
shoot them that's why we call it larping
it is it's really funny i was that i was
at one of these protests it was a riot
slash protest it was a right because
antiques should have attacked people but
it was a bunch of it was like patriot
prayers a bunch of right-wing groups
singing
religious songs in a park in a federal
park in portland antifa showed up with
weapons and bricks
and they were they were chanting nazi
larpers at the right wingers
who didn't even pay attention to
anything they were saying the right-wing
group showed up showed up literally to
have an event
to be religious it was like a religious
event antifa showed up
thinking they were nazis accusing them
of being
live at larp is live-action role-play
and i'm talking to these people and i'm
like you realize they don't know or care
about who you are or what you're doing
they're singing songs about jesus
literally they were singing songs about
jesus and america you guys have shown up
dressed in black with weapons thinking
you're fighting in a war
you're live-action role-playing there's
no war it's just
it's just like there's a 50 year old guy
there with a beard and he's in he's he's
talking about why he likes religion
he's not talking about oppressing
anybody you guys have shut up to attack
and beat people
this is what they do they they need a
purpose their lives are meaningless yes
and so they found something to fill the
void so they go around
thinking they're fighting this grand
battle as la resistance when in reality
the cops are like
these dumb kids the charges get dropped
they get told to go home
at a certain point you gotta you've
gotta punish the kids
you know what i mean and i'm not saying
lengthy prison sentences or beatings or
anything like that i'm saying
at a certain point you arrest them you
charge them and then they get you know
two weeks in jail or something or a
month in jail whatever the penalty is
for burning down buildings and smashing
windows uh
right now it's baby proofed it's baby
proof they they
know they're not gonna get hurt and what
what really chaps me
is watching what's happening with the uh
capitol hill people from january 6th
yeah they're getting they're getting
their bricks done they're getting
they're getting the book thrown at them
and then guys importantly are getting
tossed out there's got to be one
standard you can't have to it is
unsustainable to have two standards
history teaches that for god's sake
people
don't flush what we have here down the
toilet for your short
term gain no no you don't understand see
the p
see all these dumb people who go around
larping don't realize that the useful
idiots for those that want the system
torn down by any
means necessary that's their intent and
so built up with them in charge
yes but it's not so much like you know i
i know many of these people i've i've
spoken with them during occupy wall
street the way they described it was
they said we want to flip the pyramid
over most people
when they hear that make a very simple
assumption you have the pyramid with the
wealthy on top and on the bottom is the
working class
you flip it over and other working class
are on top you know what i said
if you took a stack of bricks in the
shape of a pyramid flipped it over it'll
crumble into a crude pyramid
yes it'll crumble into a pile of bricks
with one of the working class on top and
they went
exactly that's gonna be us yeah that's
gonna be us me and my house
so they're not talking about taking the
system and
they're quite literally talking about
burning everything you hold dear to the
ground
and then standing on top of the rubbles
and yelling at you to go fetch them
water and food
they know the end result of this will be
total cast and destruction
they want it because to them being the
king of chaos
is better it's a higher standard of
living than they are as a working-class
individual
so maybe there's you know hundreds of
millions of working-class people in this
country
they don't care they think that they'd
be better off doubling their net worth
if that they would make themselves the
richest people in the country
with a net worth of 100 bucks if it
meant they were the richest person in
the world they would destroy
everything just to be on top of
everybody else it is absolute
corruption and and drive for power no i
i think you're correct
and i also
think that they have not thought this
through
particularly well there are you know
history is rife with examples
of people pushed too far and right now
we have a system where people
still believe in the system at essence
people are still using the court system
they're you still using the law they're
still appealing to the media
and it doesn't always work it doesn't
work the way it should
but it's not complete chaos yet but boy
what if it was and people
realized i've got nothing to lose then
it's then you
start seeing really ugly potential stuff
and that's what we have to stop
you you know that's that's but you know
what these
antifa types and far leftists actually
will survive a lot better than your
average american
now i don't mean conservatives like the
conservatives who are paying attention
to news
who know how to use guns and know how to
actually be out in the wilderness and do
hard work
well they're going to be in the top tier
in let's say the entire country breaks
down for some reason
and it's just chaos survivalists are
going to be the kings of the castle
they've already got their castles they
got their food they don't need nothing
from you and they're armed to the teeth
you're going to have a series of of
conservative groups and ex-military who
are going to be doing very very well
organizing they've already got their
friends they've already got their
training
they'll they'll you know harden up plus
the militias regular liberals will be at
the very bottom
antifa will be above them these regular
urban city types who've never fired a
gun
who've never grown food who just work in
their office job
will have nothing no skill translatable
to the real world in terms of survival
it is uh you know i i remember reading
uh max
brooks uh world war z it's a very
entertaining book
yeah and there is a scene in there where
a uh
a rich per rich lady is being taught how
to clean houses
and by her former maid right the whole
society is broken down again the
dystopian thing
psi is broken down and the maid is
teaching this woman how to clean houses
because everybody's got to have a skill
because everybody's got to work okay you
can't be a diversity consultant anymore
you know we don't need any more gender
studies teachers uh we need somebody who
knows how to disinfect a toilet so
people don't get sick
field sanitation is an important thing
and uh i i j
that that just struck me a lot of these
people
rely on the framework of society
that they're busy supporting the people
undermining that's right and it's just
it's
it's baffling to me and look i've i saw
society break down in the la riots
i was in los angeles with the army for
three weeks
and i also saw what happened in kosovo
and i know history none of this is a
surprise
tell us about uh how the la riots uh
kicked off and what was going on and why
were you down there well i was uh i had
gotten out of the army
and i had sold all my guns uh back in
germany and i was in
a mistake well in retrospect i was
living in pasadena
and i joined went and joined the cal
national guard uh an infantry unit in
inglewood
which is uh it's a much nicer place than
it was back in
19 or 1992. and uh
the uh verdict came down from simi
valley where they acquitted the police
officers
that was so rodney king rodney king cops
get off yeah
and uh trouble started and i'm watching
the news and i
you know i'm new to the unit i call up
hey are we getting mobilized no of
course we're not getting mobilized i go
oh okay i know enough about the army to
pack but i didn't have a gun
so i'm like damn okay so i pack like an
hour later yeah we're mobilizing get
down here so i gotta drive into south
central
okay no gun and i have a chevy beretta
not a beretta pistol beretta car and i
drive up to this
um uh lapd
uh roadblock a guy's got a uh remington
870 shotgun he comes up to me goes
what the hell are you doing here i go i
i gotta go to my army unit he goes what
he got a gun i said no
he said you still want to go in there i
said not really but i don't have a
choice he goes drive real fast
stuff's burning so boom i drive in
and all most of my guys were from south
central
and they were all packed the army
in its finances they had a bunch of guns
right they their own were they like here
you go buddy
uh well i believe me there i saw more
guns there than i'd ever seen in my life
uh all the military ammo had been
centralized at one location because it's
easier to count that way
a little hard to distribute but uh
everybody had guns
uh and uh you know we we went out on the
street very soon thereafter
and uh three weeks and it was uh it was
very ugly and i was in the battalion
commander's vehicle and we drove around
and
it was uh it was an ugly scene but there
but
there there was no law and order
i mean all the things we take for
granted
we're just completely gone things were
burning
people are scared yeah the koreans on
the roofs with their rifles
uh they knew how to regulate now now
we're hearing because uh
there's this like rise in hate crimes
against asians asians are getting armed
like crazy
good i support every american owning
that's the
that's that's the legend of the the roof
koreans
yeah in the la riots did you see any of
that stuff
i don't remember i don't think i was in
korea today right i lived in creighton
briefly it's crazy
crazy to imagine this like i would go
for frozen yogurt i couldn't imagine
someone shooting from the room remember
all these guys were
rock soldiers right their republic of
korea
everybody everybody in korea does a tour
in the military
so these and they're tough dudes i mean
they're they're a real military
these flight games you've seen these
photos the dude's got got a cigarette
and he's holding the rifle
yeah he had a a me 14 and a cigarette
just smiling
and it's like these and they all had
military training and they did not play
nope and uh people were like okay maybe
we don't try and knock off this liquor
store
um frankly i think every american look
if you are a adult
american citizen who is inclined to do
it because i understand are people who
have moral
issues about weapons and violence i
don't in
that way i'm not a i'm not a pacifist
but if you do
i give you a pass i think everybody else
uh needs to have
uh uh firearms and sufficient training
to be able to defend themselves their
family their community and their
constitution
yeah this is a i also think everybody
ought to know basic medical stuff
how do you stop the bleeding how do you
do cpr how do you do a heimlich maneuver
i think look
as citizens we just we we don't even we
we seem to think everything can be
outsourced bro
um we have become jelly donuts we we
used to
i do does the average person know how to
do cpr does the average person know how
to tend to a bleed
do a tie a tourniquet no any kind of
basic
survival medical fighting in any combat
like
i watch these videos of people getting
into fights and i'm like what is he
doing like
they're just like cartoon versions of
fighting because people don't know the
basics
of defense of anything and this is not
about being aggressive and going out and
causing trouble
this is being able to do your duty as a
citizen
to have order and safety in society
if you go to a car wreck i carry i carry
a ready bag in my car
right so i got i got stuff i got
tourniquet
i got uh uh the blood uh
uh the uh leading stop gauze stuff
uh some israeli packet i mean if i have
to do something look i'm not
i'm not an emt but you know if you've
got a sucking chest wound i'll probably
be able to
keep you alive until the mts get you
there do you know why you should carry
around a first aid kit
sometimes it rains we know it rains yes
sometimes this rain causes car crashes
yes it actually rains quite a bit
yes it actually causes quite a bit of
car crashes yes you never know when it's
going to be you
your friend or someone you stumble upon
and you know i look at these disasters
we've seen just with the with the
weather in texas
and i'm wondering how many of these
people just had no idea because we are
so soft
yes that everything's taken care of for
us we have nothing to worry about
anymore
have you seen the movie wall-e the
little robot cleaning up the earth right
and the big fat humans are in those
floating chairs doing nothing and
they're confused
the guy thinks the book is called manuel
with his manual he can barely even read
it's idiocracy man we we are weakening
ourselves to the point where we will
regret it because
we are in a golden age or we're coming
out of one yes where everything was
comfortable and we're wealthy and it's
just
energy everywhere super cheap we have we
have the summation of human knowledge in
our pockets
we argue with strangers and look at cats
on a moment's notice
and for this we have distracted
ourselves to the point where a fire
could start in our homes
which is fairly common and then people
will freak out spin in circles confused
what to do
or my favorite one more thing in the
ferguson riots
i'm in the ferguson riots and i hear
gunshots
the first thing i do hit the deck i look
to my right my camera guy all right on
the ground and i'm like good man
and then i saw that video from cnn where
the woman is live
and they're asking what's going on your
gunshots and she goes oh
oh oh oh oh oh and she's just wiggling
her arms in the air like she has no idea
i'm like lady get behind a building what
are you doing and then she runs into uh
into a gangway between two buildings
and i'm like it is is remarkable they
send these people out on the streets
i've watched so many journalists here
gun shots go off and go
those gunshots and everyone's on the
ground and i'm like bro
at least you can say when in rome right
if you watch people hit the ground after
after a bang goes off
and you're not doing that maybe there's
something you need to understand about
what these people in the community
understand
well if they they probably know a little
better and i like the way that you
mentioned
rome because you see any parallels and
it's not a perfect parallel
but the romans were the height of uh
height of civilization and when they
were great
in the early in the republic period in
the
early empire you know it was regular
citizens who went out and made up their
army
it was affluent citizens you actually
had a property qualification
to become a soldier you were invested
in it and you would go out and you would
leave your farm and you would be gone
for 10 years campaigning against
you know hannibal or whoever and uh
yeah and there was greatness and then
that stopped and they started saying
well
maybe maybe you know flavius why should
i go
we'll just get uh you know hans from uh
across the rhine he'll come we'll pay
him a few uh
a few ducats and uh he'll uh he'll do
our fighting for us
and pretty soon there was you know
germanic uh
germanic empires yep and then when the
conflict actually comes
instead of being like spartans you know
like king leonidas
killing the messenger and kicking them
into the pit they became the flailing
ceiling
and journalists going oh they're coming
they have spears what do we do
and almost quite literally when attila
came they they sent
basement like the you know a roman
priest out with a bunch of gold to
talk him out of it which he managed to
do strangely well so so talking about
the law right it's like think about the
people there who just took
think about when the when everything
broke down who the people were who just
went and took whatever they wanted
those people understood survival and
when there was no rule of law they said
i don't care it's me or you so they're
going to go out and do whatever they
want yeah
well it's interesting i think if you
look at a city like los angeles
imagine the chinese take down our water
system
and our logistics system suddenly the
water
pumps stop the the uh
the the sewage system stops because they
go in and they
they wreck the computer code and the
logistics system stops so you're getting
no food
10 12 million people with nothing to
drink and nothing to eat and you know
what they're gonna do
oh my god they're gonna eat each other
yeah that's right
no i mean literally they will be
drinking drinking each other's blood in
three
four days it's
people don't get this man new york 2.5
million people on manhattan island
when when if the water shuts down and
it's and it's shut down before like
there was a power outage when sandy hit
and things were very very disastrous
it was scary it wasn't as bad it was
only a couple weeks but i remember lines
out the door of the bodegas and they had
two big guys with like baseball bats
standing in front of the buildings in
front of these bodegas
because there was no electricity it was
all cash exchange
everything that was perishable perished
and so you had lukewarm water and
gatorades and things like that you could
buy the dry goods you could buy or the
canned goods
but imagine if it was sustained for
longer than that um
things would get very scary very quickly
uh you know i
still tend to keep my uh my cars fueled
yeah i mean if they start it starts
getting halfway to empty i'm like
i just did just yesterday it's just you
know i i remember
the wildfires in california which if
we've had numerous stories of this
i commanded uh two battalions during the
2007
what happens if you live in these areas
and your your car is on
you know an eighth of a tank and fire
breaks out yeah you die
you die that's why you keep your car
fueled that's why you keep your electric
car charged if you have an electric car
and i mean this this stuff isn't super
hard
it's just not internalized
because we've never had to worry about
these
problems but the problems will come to
you eventually
uh and i think that's the one bro i
think that's why the covet thing
is people's wood stock i think they are
excited about it
i mean look they don't want 500 000
people to die
but you know it's kind of there's a
little risk not much i mean if you're
healthy you're
99.5 percent going to survive life's
boring lifespan
things now it's exciting i've got to
wear a mask i remember going into trader
joe's
and uh my beautiful wife was with me and
we're looking around at people taking
stuff off the shelves they're not going
crazy but they're they're loading up and
the shelves were
getting empty and it was a little scary
no i i wasn't like terrified but it was
like okay you know i'm tense
i'm intense other people but people were
excited about it
and they they were actually behaving
very well and there were there were a
lot of good humor
but you know it's something different
it's something new i feel
i feel more alive when i was in the
riots when i was in the war even though
i re
look i was so far in the rear after
fedex bullets to hit me i literally ran
a heavily armed car wash so i'm not
trying to come along as pete butterjudge
or
dick blumenthal or any of the war heroes
but when you're in a situation like that
when you're part of this kind of
massive event that's historical and
there's this little element of danger in
it
it's exciting yep and you you remember
it and it's i'm not gonna call it fun
but
god i wouldn't have missed it for the
world that's what uh
drives a lot of journalism you know the
the reason i wanted to travel around
covering these stories was to experience
these major historical moments
and i always tell people look i've been
skateboarding my whole life i'm an
adrenaline junkie i used to jump off
buildings when i was like 16.
so you tell me i can go into a conflict
zone and it's meaningful work that's
important to a lot of people and you can
share their story and tell the world's
happening
and you're running full speed you're
like it's intense
it makes you feel like what you're doing
matters yes it gives you a a feeling of
risk or danger
so you get a reward you know mental
reward after you've you've made it
through these things
and many of them i didn't go into war i
wasn't in anything like you were you
know you said you were
in the car wash well i was in civil
unrest and civil conflict
granted a revolution here and there and
some pretty dangerous neighborhoods
i was in the favelas in brazil i had
some turkish anarchists holding a
molotov cocktail to my face threaten me
but not in anything where it was like
enemy factions who would kidnap and
murder me it was mostly like
i'd get beat up and thrown out or
whatever but it was it's
it's exhilarating yeah and it's
and i i think people need something like
that i think they seek it
i think they want it i think there are a
lot of people who don't want this to end
because it also excuses a lot of things
if you if you're one of those depressos
i'm not staying at home because i can't
force myself to go out and socialize
i'm staying at home because i've got to
save lives
it's an excuse it's an excuse and it
empowers them
and it god and you hear these people and
all it is time about the vaccines
vaccines vaccines
okay i i had coveted i caught it working
for the
president in nevada um and
uh it was uh
it was like a bad cold not bad cold and
okay cold
in terms of the severity of it in terms
of severity now there are other people
who
who died from it and it could hurt
people and of course as soon as you get
it
right yeah i got covered oh i had this
friend whose friend
was a 21 year old triathlete and he got
in two days later he spontaneously
combusted so i'll clarify just for the
the youtube people who are listening
you're talking about
how it felt yes death rate and i'll
clarify because they just deleted one of
uh crowder's videos for this
the death rate is substantially worse
than a cold or the flu oh yeah no
but they deleted my experience no people
die from this thing there's
five hundred thousand people's
statistics have died from
it is a real thing it is
it is also if you're in good health
you're probably gonna make it 99.95
for people under 70. yeah and then when
you factor in 70 years it's 97.5 percent
survival yeah so
that that is uh so it's something it is
it is it is something it's it's
definitely worse than the flu
yes primarily impacting seniors and
people with co-morbidities yes
but man do they love to censor anybody
the moment they step out of line on this
one
i'm just telling you what i i'm just
telling you my personal experience with
it
um and uh but i
i think a lot of people you were
mentioning the vaccines getting the
vaccine
yeah yeah i mean you know people people
talking about the vaccine all the time
okay and i've been told uh you know even
though i had it i should go get the
vaccine
so um people the problem the problem is
that fauci
has been telling people it doesn't
matter and that that well that's that
that seems to me to be super
wrong-headed
yeah if you actually want people to take
the vaccine
because it doesn't make any sense it's
either effective or it isn't
this what i've seen says it's effective
so
why is he down trump thinks it's
effective but fauci is telling people oh
we don't know so you just might as well
stay home lock your door and you know
he could do a better job let's let's i
want to talk about the
the political conflict because you
mentioned that you know we're basically
talking about people are not prepared
for when things break down
yes if if chaos erupted you know you
you were in the l.a riots i mean you
were in war i've seen my fair share of
riots
i'll tell you this look i was so far in
the back i had to watch flashes on the
horizon
that's more than most people have ever
seen look the last thing i want to do is
come across
as mr mister martial comeback guy again
i ran a decontamination platoon we did a
very good job
i was not a hero i didn't get shot at i
didn't shoot anybody
well there you go let's uh i i want to
get into the stuff what's going on with
the the democrats so we have a couple
stories i want to highlight and we'll go
through this quickly because i want to
highlight the political turmoil
not necessarily the democrats the
republicans just the instability
so we have the story from cnn house
democrats way ejecting gop winner of
contested iowa race
dismissing comparisons to trump's effort
to overturn the election
quite literally this is a republican who
won the state certified she won
a bipartisan panel certified this
republican one
and the democrats have voted to move
forward with a review to see
if they will eject a republican sitting
member of congress who duly won her
election
and replace her with a democrat we also
have
73 democrats sign efforts to expel
marjorie taylor green from the house
after she's already been removed from
her committees
now we have them going after brett
kavanaugh with vanity fair writing could
brett kavanaugh be booted from the
supreme court
we talk a lot about politics i get it
but how much of this
is oh let's have an argument about who
did who who should be in the supreme
court
how much of this is our system is
completely gone it's broken
when the moment they said i know he's
already on the supreme court
let's reopen investigation anyway i know
she's literally a duly elected
representative
let's remove her now at what point do we
just say we have no elections
if they're going to be doing this after
the fact once again this relates to
what we've been talking about for the
last hour or so which is the complete
destruction of our institutional norms
for short-term convenience it's always
short-term convenience oh
with donald trump he's he's literally
hitler so we've got to uh uh get rid of
this whole objectivity thing for the
news media
yeah you know and then the military's
now now you know this slippery slope
now now the military well you know we've
had a civil military uh separation for
uh 204 years
we'll just spark the biggest crisis in
civil military relations since uh
macarthur because because because tucker
said things we think are mean
he did say mean things though you know
and those and and we as very soft
delicate cookie dough americans can't
handle mean words
you know words are violence at least
that's what they've been telling me now
so when i i mean look at us we're
sitting here talking about
you know you literally having dealt with
the la riots
and having deployed and served in the
military much more than i can speak for
uh
but i've been in riots as well and i'm
looking at a bunch of people that think
words are violence
like okay i watched someone get shot i i
personally got
shot by a ricochet of a pepper ball
which sprayed my face
with plastic bits and went my eyes and
and took me down a bit
i've run through walls of tear gas in
turkey and brazil
and the united states and i'm not going
to pretend like i'm some super soldier
i'm just some dude who's actually seen
some stuff but
if i've seen that and we've got one the
political conflict
the institutional breakdown our military
is freaking out about gadsden flags
every little institution like you
mentioned they're breaking apart
confidence in the system is breaking
moral frameworks are have
there's two different total moral
frameworks it feels like in my opinion
we are heading towards
well what should we call a prepper's
dream
what they've they've long i mean i'll
tell you this i see these these twitter
posts from preppers
and they post how they're laughing i
remember i was i drove
at the beginning of covid i drove across
the u.s
we i was i went to a gas station and you
know it's at the toilet paper craze
and i asked the the the you know the
lady at the counter and we were in
arizona
and she goes oh we're not worried about
any of that we're preppers
we got months worth of everything
stocked up and always have so we laugh
at everybody when this happens
yep so i i'll try i want to try and keep
it wrapped up in you know
just stemming into the political
conversation
vanity fair is actually asking if they
could boot brett kavanaugh because
who was it was it a senator was it white
house white house said the fbi didn't
actually do
a legitimate review it was fake so
they're trying to reignite
yeah they said that a lot of people were
trying to send tips to the fbi about
kavanaugh
but apparently chris wray was classmates
with kavanaugh
and they're both members of the
federalist society so ray didn't
actually do the investigation
they're trying to get pretext it seems
to remove a supreme court justice
to remove two gop reps they already took
marjorie taylor green off of her her
committees i bring this up just to talk
about the institutional decay
to say like at what point does this stop
and do we recover
or is this just the the crumbling of the
infrastructure that leads to the chaos
there's there's going to be one one or
two directions
either it continues and there's chaos or
people say whoa
stop now we saw uh that young lady
canceled
uh today a very liberal lady canceled a
a a woman of uh
a leftist woman of color was fired or
she was forced to resign and jonathan
swann got on twitter and said this is
terrible this is wrong of course
he got ratioed with people going this is
what you wanted
yeah this is what you've been cheering
uh either people stop it
or it continues what what is rewarded
you get more of
and so far this stuff has been rewarded
always
if it goes on i mean it's ugly look i
i've got five
novels of america falling apart that i
sell a ton of people's republic go get
your copy today
people were actually commenting they
said that they uh one person commented
they read your book and loved it and
it's eerily similar to what's happening
it worries them
it kind of freaks me out because when i
wrote the first one people's republic in
2016.
it was a warning i love this country i
love what we have here i've lived
overseas for years
i've seen places that don't work and it
and it rips me up to see us squandering
the legacy we've been granted
we didn't earn it we didn't build it
here we were handed it we need to
maintain it we're not doing that sounds
like obama remember he's like you didn't
build that
well in this case it's correct yeah we
did not build these institutions we
inherited it
we could have made them better but you
know
we we've already gone down that road so
i wrote these books and i was thinking
you know what's the wildest thing you
know uh people
what craziness uh people being arrested
for
uh being transphobic uh you know thought
there was that there was that guy who
got arrested because he i think was in
canada
that was canada yeah he refused to refer
to his uh
daughter as his daughter uh yes well
this is complicated you know it's it's a
court battle between
the the parents and the court as to
whether or not the child has the right
to be
the 13 year old yeah maybe 14.
so the issue is if it was a clear-cut
case where we had quotes from a
you know trans boy a transgender you
know 14 year old who said specifically
they were
then i can talk about what that person
was saying we have a legal battle
when you have a judge saying i don't
care what your legal argument is about
your children you must say this or you
know what i mean seems like they've
already decided
right so and we saw that other legal
battle in texas
well that that's you know again
institutional decay when
but back to your book i don't want to
derail from your your time up about the
book go buy the damn book
all five of them you were mentioning you
were mentioning that people were getting
arrested for like crazy things yeah eric
and i write this stuff and it starts
happening and i'm thinking
successively more crazy stuff as i'm
writing the
subsequent books and it's happening and
people write me going
this is all happening and it's like i
don't want this to happen this is not a
hell too
i'm not for any of this but they don't
listen
it's this institutional decay look what
institution
defends us regular people now can you go
to the courts and be
sure that you're going to get a fair
shake can you go to the fbi can you go
to
congress can you go to the media can you
go to academia academia's gonna tell you
you're uh
you're you know you're a white
supremacist which was really published
puzzling to the guy who drives a truck
for a living when he's being told by a
guy who makes four times as much
you know uh uh doing diversity articles
uh that that he's oppressing sounds like
you're saying we already lost
i don't think we've ever you made it you
made a really scary point i'll tell you
that
think about this for everybody listening
do you feel like if you went to court
if you called the police if you called
the fbi for any for any issue do you
think they would actually have
your back would they support you as an
american citizen would you get a fair
shot would you get a fair shot see the
the beauty of
a democratic republic a free country
is you know maybe you lose the election
but you're like well okay i lost
but you know i lost be i i made my case
better luck next time or i went to court
i didn't like the way the jury came out
but
i got a chance to make my piece and i
think it was fair right that's that's
the basis and you don't have that
youtube has a rule
that if you say something specific in
relation to donald trump in the election
they'll delete
your video and give you a strike donald
trump's made statements that have been
removed from youtube
and his own speeches have gotten
people's
news outlets like right side
broadcasting network out of strike i
believe simply for broadcasting trump's
speech yet
if you relay what the democrats have
said about rita hart in iowa
which is in many ways similar to what
donald trump said
you are fine you are allowed to advocate
for what the democrats have called for
contesting a
certified election that's okay on
youtube
that's that's that's that's the silicon
valley bias right there
well it's hugely biased and i think
it's another example short-term thinking
because right now well it's such an
emergency
we've got to do this exceptional thing
of course the exception becomes the rule
when it becomes the rule it eventually
becomes the rule for everybody
and the worm eventually turns
and someday they could be scratching
their heads going gosh
i don't seem to have a lot of friends
left
i look i don't think we've ever lost
until our heart stop bleep beating
i i am always an optimist i understand
that
what we had in america and what i think
we're on the verge of losing if we don't
watch it
is so much greater than what's been in
any other culture any other place uh
certainly any other place i've been
there's something about it it's so
powerful it's so right
you know and i'm not one of those guys
the right side of
history oh god but what we what we're
selling
freedom civil rights individuality free
enterprise
uh the rule of law this is great stuff
and people have sacrificed a huge amount
for it
and people from other countries like my
wife come here
to get that so i'm calling a pipe though
look it's running right but we're not
done yet and i i will never give up as
long as i'm alive
i will never give up and just say oh
we're done no i agree
i will certainly use their rules against
them because some people need to learn
through pain
i guess the issue is when
the right does anything that the left
does they're held to a very very strict
standard
if conservatives go out and protest they
call it you know a far-right
insurrection
revolt with the left that's what they'll
call a peaceful protest of course and we
gotta understand that
uh you know the media and the
establishment
are our opponents uh i think that's one
reason you see fewer conservatives being
canceled now
is that it it no longer works on us
we have enough of our own
outlets it's not perfect you can get
canceled off youtube you might have to
go someplace else
but we can still get our message out
there and they can't cancel us
so they're turning inward yeah let's
let's get a little optimistic i suppose
we have this story from the new york
times
well i i'll say fairly optimistic teen
vogue editor resigns after
fury over racist tweets the hiring of
alexi mccammon who was supposed to start
the conde nast publication next week
drew complaints because of racist and
homophobic tweets she had posted a
decade ago
alexia mccammond is a black woman i i
believe i
i don't the news calls her a female you
know person of color whatever but
i believe she's black and uh
she got cancelled for being racist
against asians
which is a fracturing in the woke
theories the critical race theory
because asians are supposed to be the
ultra privileged it's like they they
they say in the sats for instance
asians have to score higher than white
people that
they have to score like a 1300 or so
compared to like a thousand or whatever
for a white person
well now you know we used to joke on the
show that i was double white for being
part asian so i'm like double privileged
now i don't know what i'm supposed to
think because apparently they're saying
that the hate crimes are against the
asian community
and this woman is getting fired for 10
year old tweets so so the reason i say
optimistic
they can't cancel every conservative no
especially when some of these people are
independent
yeah when uh when you have people who
have their own youtube channels or work
for conservative outlets who will never
get fired
what do they do well they're like
they're like vampires you know
they have a bloodlust and they're
searching for someone to
softest target but you know the
conservatives are hardened
have their shields up and are defending
their communities so they're turning on
themselves in desperation
exactly you go for the soft target look
i i get on twitter i say thing i get the
leftists attacking me
so what i don't care i don't care the
people who publish me don't care the
people who buy my books don't care
probably sells more books to be honest
uh maybe
and and by the way the uh uh battling
hierarchy
of oppressions was one of the topics in
in the books
the uh flag of the people's republic
america splits into two countries
flag of the people's republic keeps
changing they keep adding stripes
and it's like a running joke through it
except
it it's except it's like real well they
they
you can't satirize these people well
they just report
have you seen so they there was the the
rainbow flag
yes then they added the black and brown
stripe for black and brown solidarity
and now they added the trans triangle to
it so it's just the flag is becoming
this is a triangle out right out rank a
stripe
i guess it's like i don't know i i mean
i don't i don't know who who's the most
depressed doll
a mirror mirror on the wall who's the
most oppressed of us all
you know it's so s the thing is
even i fall into making the mistake of
calling it stupid
it is stupid but that's beside the point
it's insidious yeah i'm not going to be
able to talk
look you can't reason them out of it you
can't sit there and go
you know it's stupid to hold people's
immutable characteristics
as defining them it's stupid it's also
immoral and wrong
on every level you're religious uh
secular
every level it's it's terrible now
believe what i do and they're like no i
get power from it screw you
yeah or you're not in the tribe so i
reject whatever it is you're saying
without evidence uh it's just
it it's ag but i think more and more
people
are coming around on it as a 30 years
ago we were talking about political
correct
politically correct stuff yeah i
remember i did
bill maher politically incorrect i know
abc got fired for being flipped
it's like about 2 000 in 1986 or
seven i was an editor of uh the uc san
diego
california review which was a
conservative paper and we had a picture
of one of us sitting there going
here fred pete is drinking a glass of
politically incorrect coors beer because
the
the coors guy gave money to right wing
thing it was being used
you know 35 years ago and uh
but it was kind of a niche thing for
conservatives conservatives whined about
it
i mean it's right to wine about but
they're still whiting now
ever it's infecting normal people's
lives and they don't like it and you saw
with president trump he he got more
hispanic voters
oh yeah because like his male guys are
like i i i didn't sign up for this
yeah yeah i wonder for this garbage i
wonder if the the the infighting
people canceling themselves i'll tell
you this this woman resigned right this
alexia mccammon resigned it's worse than
that
uh we reported this before but a seven
figure advertising deal was pulled
because the employees were complaining
about their new boss
so they uh the company effectively
canceled itself
you understand like this is amazing
millions of dollars
i don't you know the the thing that
really got me was the new york times
with tom cotton
oh yeah where you had a senator writing
an article which i disagreed with by the
way i
actually wrote my law review article on
the use of military force in support of
civilian civil support operations
i'm largely against it i think the
military's unsuited
in most cases when it's not emergency
here that neither here
there he writes an article that says we
should use these guys we should use
military forces
to suppress some of the blm rioting
a anti-foreign about half of americans
take he's a republican
they run this thing the news the the
woke
kids at the new york times go nuts
and if i was the editor and they marched
into my office and said you can't run
this i'd say
okay you're at the new york times we
run editorials from everybody if you
don't like it
get out if you do like it get out do
your job
and the next one of you who brings up
this crap to me is gonna find himself
walking the streets
get out i gotta say i can't do it i
gotta stop you right there if it's me
and someone comes in and says that op-ed
you published
you need to get rid of it i would say
okay you're all fired everyone in the
office right now you've just lost
your job i'll call security to escort
you out of the building you're nicer
than me because i would give them a
learning opportunity i think i teach
them
not to be idiots but if they didn't do
it i would fire them
granted i wouldn't hire them in the
first place well that's that's also true
but let's let's
for the sake of the hypothetical the
thing is they rolled over
the guys in power rolled over why
they had one of these boomers all you
gotta do is say no these guys have a
glass jaw
hey hey millennials
screw you we're not doing any of that
even if i hear about it again
you can you know you could do the person
who's like
you know speaking you say you're fired
anyone else
anyone else want to be fired all right
you know you work you guys believe that
look you guys believe this is so
important let's see some principles
i'm not gonna pound the table yeah how
many are you gonna question no no put on
the table
and then they'd come back and be like we
need a union to fight against these
things
and uh that's because they can't they
can't
negotiate for themselves and stand up
for their own ideas have you noticed how
the uh
uh new woke unions tend to not support
basic workers like old school union uh
we want to you know we want vacation and
we want health care
dental plan dental plan you know that
old school teamster kind of stuff now
it's all uh
we uh we got this whole woke agenda
we've got it for us blah blah
you see the united auto workers union oh
they're outraged
ford is going to be moving some of their
new car projects to mexico
and and it was really funny my favorite
line from ford was they were like well
things have changed since uh you know
circumstances changed
since our last contract negotiation and
do you know what that thing that changed
was
yes who was it it was the president
right who was it i said it right away
now it's that withered old zombie and
uh who is in hocked understand that the
big corporations
tend to be part of the liberal
establishment the democrat establishment
you know this whole i i saw they were uh
you know warren's
son we gotta have a billionaire tax i'm
like
let's do it let's tax the billionaires
you think
why why again would i spend hey look i'm
a republican i'm not just a concern i am
a republican
because i believe there's got to be a
party of the right and it's the
republicans for better
and mostly worse mostly worse but
why should we as republicans spend a
night oda
of our political capital defending the
financial influence interests of people
who
hate us and use their money to screw us
against our own financial interests
let them burn bigger 20 percent yeah
you want to you got tax on billionaires
rock and roll yeah uh mackenzie bezos
funds a ton of critical race theory
george soros man conservatives don't
shut up about that guy
so when i hear that stuff i'm like who
cares about billionaires so i tweet
out you know like tax the rich and all
these i saw that all these lefties are
like
based tim like tim's a lib and i'm like
dude i've always talked about
progressive taxes
tax the billionaires i don't care
there's like how many of them in this
country a handful
well look i oh there's 300. if i wanted
to get back to my basic conservative
principles from when i used to read a
national review on ironically um
and god helped me weekly standard before
it became a
cheesy cruise brochure uh look
i i would say look i i want a smaller
government i want people paying less
taxes because that stars government
that's a principle but i have another
conservative principle and it's a more
important one it's
i will i will accept no principle
that makes me less free and
unfortunately you get all these
conservatives
well you know it's a private company
can't do nothing
that sounds like the democrats right now
well it's like yeah
and it's like well yeah but
i kind of don't like them screwing with
me and if you use your power against me
i'm going to use my power against them
and uh if we're going to play the
principles game i say they go first this
is about screwing me
the weirdest arguments you know i have
with uh objectivists or libertarians
we we had a river so polluted it started
on fire was it there was a coyote
yeah hogan uh 70s i think it was and
then we had we had a
regulation to be like okay how about you
can't dump that much pollution in the
water we got to regulate how much you're
doing
basically all these different companies
are saying don't look at me i only
dumped you know a tiny fraction it's
like yeah when all of you dump at the
same time it makes a big mess and burst
into flames
when our water is on fire we got
problems that's that would be an
indicator
so i've always i grew up with this stuff
i've always been in favor of regulating
companies that get out of control
and i also believe in some form of
regulation against government was out of
control the problem is
the government has a monopoly on force
so how do you deal with
a broken government that's tough however
i'm not going to ignore
when billionaires are exploiting the
system and taking advantage of the
working class
my my thing is i don't care if you're a
billionaire bro
like people talk about taxes and i made
a joke where i said i said tax the rich
right
and then a bunch of people were like
look at a mirror bro and then i quote
two to myself me and bernie will share
i said i said arrest the rich as a joke
and i was like me and bernie will share
a cell i have um
i have a jo i'm writing my sixth book
and i'll give you a preview i have a
joke about there's a statue of bernie
sanders the late bernie sanders
because he he he passed away when he
dropped his bong
on some copies of socialist workers and
it caught the house on fire but the fire
department went to the wrong mansion
and it's a sad thought look no
no one does better under communism than
the cadre yeah
right i mean you know and uh there are a
lot of mensheviks running around
uh democrat washington a lot of these
guys oh
it's like your own people are gonna put
you against the wall figuratively
they openly these people tweet these
things i know
they they they look when i when i hear
about bernie sanders
bernie sanders having multiple houses
and millions of dollars i'm like i don't
care
what are his principles is he in favor
of working class people having rights or
not well
arguably you can say yes to some
ideological split but it's fine okay i
think bernie sold out in a lot of ways
but then i look at soros the koch
brothers the mercers jeff bezos
mackenzie bezos
tom steyer michael bloomberg why do
these people get to shut down the voices
of the working class
with their with their massive wealth and
not only that
but the the establishment that they
that they embody has been a disaster to
the american working class i i wrote
another book a non-fiction called
militant normals about normal
people getting angry at what's happening
and i i
told the story of a guy who was a marine
he comes home
you know fictional and embellish it but
but basically you know he sees his job
sent to another country and a guy who
looks like mitt romney drives up in a
limousine and
says well you know you guys you know you
can basically learn to code
solar panels you know build some solar
panels got to go
i got to be at the uh i got to be at the
club
and why why were republicans allowing
the heart and soul of our country to be
screwed they were being screwed
what is the principle that requires
the impoverishment of the people who
make up
the american middle class the one who
built this country feed it fuel it
defend it
and i don't see it and i i gotta give
donald trump credit for opening the eyes
of a lot of people
by saying what needed to be said he's up
there there's one guy he's one guy
there's 16 other guys
who are all talking about basically the
same stuff george bush was talking about
and donald trump's talking about the
real problems that people are talking
about
our jobs going away are our culture
being hollowed out
uh wars that don't make any sense again
i'm not a pacifist
by any means but you know
as as i pointed out in my article today
you know the military's pretty angry at
tucker carlson but
uh tucker carlson has uh won as many
wars as they have in the last 20 years
he's also lost fewer that's right
and who pays that price it's not
the sons and daughters who go to harvard
west lake in west l.a
it's the paratrooper uh from uh omaha
hey well look you know we're really good
at building infrastructure in middle
eastern countries and really bad at
building it here
okay i'm driving around the carpet
what the hell you know the the the
afghanistan papers
that the washington post published
should have been a scandal on par with
the pentagon papers
about the disaster in vietnam and it
just kind of went
poof what were they uh it basically
talked about
all our mistakes in afghanistan after 20
years a war we have not won after 20
years
uh the waste of money the waste of lives
the flawed strategy
it's it's been a disaster and
look i i was not i wasn't against iraq
going in
and iraq went really well for about two
months
no follow-through strategy is not just
about
winning one battle strategy is about
achieving
objectives big objectives
and there was no strategy i mean i
literally got
they literally sent me to the army war
college get me a degree in strategy
i must have made a mistake because i
listened you know i mean i i took it
seriously
and i'm looking at this i'm going okay
this vi these things violate everything
i was taught about strategy
and i i just you know
avoiding the hard questions when when
you have
full kernels you know bro you know
colonels
tomorrow you're going to brief us on
america's greatest threat
you know what is our greatest strategic
threat and then the next day you will
brief us on your
your your strategy to address it basic
basic kind of war ecology thing and this
is a story somebody from a different war
college
gave but it's tracks with my own um
the first day 50 of the teams of
colonels briefed
climate change the weather in a hundred
years
was america's greatest strategic threat
according to guys who typically command
5 000 americans wow i mean you're just
like
what the hell you know
look an environment let's assume it's
even true let's assume
climate change is into giant hoax and
the scam uh
because it's one of those problems that
seems every solution happens to be
exactly every policy prescription
its advocates always wanted anyway but
that's that's an environmental factor
that is a factor in the situation
the correlation it's not a threat it's a
factor of the private
market private industries if if we've
got all of these different companies
polluting and individuals driving cars
the military is not going to solve
that's going to be legislative
or it's going to be cultural well it's
like what what
what do you think the military i do stop
not have m1 tanks because they bust out
but you know they have to
have they have to storm the beaches of
you know uh
greenland san pedro and uh and uh you
know new york
to uh you know shut down the importing
of all these petrochemical based
products
and then they got to raid all of these
car manufacturing plants the military
has nothing to do with this no it has
nothing to do and it should be
its purpose should be to deter defeat
america's enemies
in in in conventional and unconventional
combat that's what it should be doing
and it
it's essentially it's become an
unserious organization when you
when you're focusing on all this other
woke stuff
that's not a serious military and i i
get emails and
communications from people who are in or
recently out
and it's bad and they're not focusing on
warfighting and i i am terrified
that one day i'm going to wake up and
the
chinese are going to have initiated
their op plan on taiwan
and our bases in guam and japan are
going to be smoking ruins
and there's going to be a carrier at the
bottom of the uh
south china sea i mean i i mean i know
what it is
trump's fault come on man where's my
slipper come on man that's it
matlock matlock marathon's on
or i'll just be he'll be sleeping it's
just
yeah who's in charge there anyway i'm
still kamala
i think she's being uh i think she's
being niced out really yeah
but she's like doing the phone call at
the world leaders doing phone calls on
behalf of biden
yeah i bet you she put that out uh yeah
you think dr jill's going to let her
uh go not doctor to get get dr jill out
of the white house
no i i think the 25th amendment uh i
i i think there is a group that wants
biden i think camelot wants camella
and i think if camelot could convince
enough people to do the 25th amendment i
think she would
kurt it's comma la is it it's racist
when you say it that way i
i am in that was that was an actual news
cycle yes i saw that i am indifferent to
what she likes about her name
uh is it kurt or cart cart yeah
anyway um but uh all i can say is
if i was joe biden and kamala came up
with a plate of cookies
let the dog test them give them to a dog
first
just wait the dogs are gone
[Laughter]
yeah i think you know looping it back to
what we were talking about initially
with putin
yeah it seems like there's a desperate
attempt to not focus on china
oh to make everything about russia so
that they don't have to worry about
that maybe it's that they know they've
already lost
with china it's hard and it's mine what
did my
mike pompeo say well like a year ago
we've been infiltrated at every level by
the chinese communist party no that that
is true
i mean look at disney hollywood's
sucking up to him
our industry sucks up to him well
where do you get your rare earth metals
you know you could theoretically get
them from basically anywhere but for
some reason we just don't
no we we we don't uh we now also don't
get our oil
or our vitamin we our vitamin c or our
antibiotics
uh it's even our masks are made in china
you know
we but i hate using the word globalist
because it
you know it brings up pictures of uh uh
guys in in basements somewhere you know
with uh
lots of uh uh post-its and uh attacks
what is it crime web conspiracy web yeah
i mean it's just
nuts but people who we made a mistake
and i bought into it too
a little bit i thought that the chinese
might come around
through free enterprise and slowly
become
more like us not just in economics but
in
individual free it didn't work out that
way guess i didn't understand that
i guess all of us didn't understand the
chinese but here's the difference
i've seen it ain't working and i've
decided it's time to change course there
are a few of us
the people who still want to go on with
the fantasy that if we're
only nice enough to china it'll be nice
to us
are not serious people
yeah i think some of them are
compromised i think there are a lot of
people with business interests in china
and they're and i'm not thinking oh well
give me five thousand dollars i'll say
whatever they want i'm thinking they
gave me five thousand dollars these guys
aren't that bad
i mean just give me some money
i think it is a lot easier
to address a problem that's not as
problematic
right like russia it's like uh you know
there's a talk about how cops will
prefer to go after
petty crime instead of serious crime
because it's easier to deal with and it
occupies their time so
pulling over someone for blowing a stop
sign versus running rushing full speed
to what looks like someone getting
mugged it's like
you know so there there are complaints
about things like that that when
government
approaches a problem they take the path
of least resistance to make it seem like
they're working well yeah
i mean that's just human nature that's
to be expected that's why you need
exceptional people
you know we we we we need a harry truman
not a joe biden you know yeah joe
biden's like our buchanan huh
he's buchanan wait no not not buchanan
wait what's up buchanan
yeah that was the guy leading up to the
civil war yeah yeah yeah buchanan like
the one of the
weakest presidents we've ever had
terrible yeah
and then you know we're gonna we're
gonna have this week president for for
several years and then come 2024 people
are going to be begging for someone like
trump again
maybe it'll be trump maybe trump will
run again maybe i mean
what's going to be 78 maybe it'll be i
think i think he's getting a little old
yeah and i i i think he'll prefer to be
king maker just my gut
i don't know anything i think desantis
uh i
i saw this ass at cpac uh he was better
retail than i thought he'd be
he's uh ex-military which is not a
necessarily a qualification but it might
lead him to be a little less
you know submissive to generals he has
done a great job in florida
he has survived the media onslaught and
showed how you do it you never give in
you're killing people no i'm not i'm
also not grabbing liberal girls breasts
um he he
said he he's done okay yeah um
i i i'm a unabashed fan of rick grinnell
who i know personally he lives in my
town and uh
i think he is an exceptional leader i
would love to see a desantis grinnell
ticket
wow and it's kind of weird because this
shows kind of the realignment
i mean who would have thought a very
cosmopolitan gay guy would have the
support of like a
military guy i'm not the only one
military guys are fanatics for rick uh
freedom freedom wins liberty wins right
yeah
i hope so well so no listen there was a
tweet from jenkins the young turks he
said something like the progressives
always win in the end or something like
that
someone corrected him saying no it's
it's liberty that wins
yes so what he was trying to say is you
go back in time and you can see that
these left-wing causes progressive
causes have won out
civil rights et cetera only the problem
is now that the left is rejecting civil
rights
they're they're opposing individualism
and freedom i also reject the whole uh
uh john lithgow and footloose vision of
conservatives through history
okay we were not the ones who always
said no you kids can't rock
kevin bacon stop your strutting it's
i don't know how my side
was somehow labeled as the side that
didn't like free speech they didn't like
the ability to write what you want
say what you want think what you want uh
it's great branding for the other side
yeah because it's all baloney
that's not what we're about it's never
been what we're about
and i think
i think certainly now that if you want
to find the defenders of traditional
uh liberal values
you're going to have to look or what
have been labeled liberal values
you've got to go to the conservatives
because the today's liberals
don't believe in those things donald
trump is uh what they call him a 90s
democrat
his policies he's been he's been likened
to bill clinton in a lot of ways
not the worst ways actually no the worst
ways by the democrats themselves yeah uh
conveniently giving bill a pass donald
trump's interesting because
he is the guy on the right
and i think he is on the right uh even
though he had some
views that are uh traditionally liberal
but he's the guy
who actually talked about what the base
was talking about
as opposed to what the bushes were
talking about jeb bush would sit and
talk to you about you know tax rates all
day
and trump would go yeah i want to put up
a border wall
so that some guy without insurance i'm a
legal alien with insurance doesn't wreck
your car
and leave you in the lurch and people
are like yeah
my buddy's car got crashed into by an
illegal airline he didn't have insurance
and he got screwed over yeah
trump talked about things that no one
else would talk about he
and also because trump is the ultimate
immune to cancellation
he just doesn't care yeah and i think
the next president has to take
not necessarily his positions and not
necessarily all the things about trump
not everything about trump but he has to
take on the not caring i think desantis
is doing that
i'm always amused by people who say you
know
i like donald trump but all that
tweeting it's like going it you know
it's like going to a fixed price menu
and asking for a substitution no i i
don't want the twice baked potato i'd
rather broccolini okay
you get the potato okay you can't have
donald trump
and all the things you like about donald
trump without the mean tweets
it is of a whole it is of a part but it
is the people who voted against him
based on his mean tweets tweets that
that hurt him in the end
i think they would vote against him
anyway yeah probably because the media
just told him to
but listen but listen if trump was
strategically silent
for even a short period of time he would
have starved the media out
look what's happening now he certainly
would have but then he wouldn't be
donald trump
that's true because if i mean you know i
i just
you know if only donald trump had all
the good things about donald trump with
not the bad things it would be great
well great if you had all the good
things about curtin none of the bad
things
i'd be wonderful right honey look it
when it when she's nodding
there's there's a lot to look at when it
comes to ron desantis
compared to trump and the things that
you know trump was doing so what i like
about trump the abraham accords were
amazing oh my god disagreements he
ended decades long
70 decades i mean i wrote my entire life
i remember the 73 war i remember sadat
getting shot
i mean because i'm old um
this was going on and on and on and my
gosh
now all these countries are at peace and
of course biden's like goldie no
no who cares well so [ __ ] up to the
molars
we get that we get the banning of
critical race theory
yes so these are things i like we get
school choice he was pushing for
uh he didn't he didn't get to push that
hard enough now i'm wondering how many
of these things will ron desantis
push as well because what he's doing in
florida with censorship
is brilliant yes what he's done with
covid has worked swimmingly banned crt
right exactly banning critical race
theory yeah the i'll clarify the
pandemic thing like look people
lost lives lost their lives in the
pandemic but i believe the death rate in
florida is eight percent below the
national average
you want to talk about what are our
objective standards for doing a good job
in the pandemic how about eight percent
below national average
is it is it are there still problems
sure but he's doing a good job
now when he steps up to the plate
assuming he does will he
will he approach some of some of the
things that trump was pushing as well of
a populist right-wing
platform one of the advantage desantis
will have especially if he
listens is he'll have the rolodex that
trump never did
trump got into office and didn't know
anybody if you had had
jeb bush the human puffball roll
into office and i i want you to assume
exclamation point every time i say jeb
yeah so we don't have to go through that
uh drill
uh jeb could have called on 5 000 people
to fill the federal government
because the bushes knew these 5 000
people muslim worked for his brother's
uh uh
administration trump didn't have that
trump's biggest problem was always
personnel including hiring generals
because he was always impressed by
generals
he shouldn't have been every single
general except for flynn seemed to stick
him
um if desantis goes in he's got a
whole bunch of veterans of the trump
administration
and he knows what the play is
which is lead people in place to disrupt
in the bureaucracy
and he's ju he's a mean dude he'll
happily go no
fire fire fire he needs to say you know
at 1201 on january i guess 20th
of uh 2025 uh i want the resignation of
every united states attorney i want the
resignation of
every uh ses
executive i want the resignation of
everyone on the joint chiefs of staff
i want the resignation of everybody
whose job i get to pick
you are all gone uh director of the fbi
mr ray
thank you for your service you are out
here is my
list and here are the people going over
to those agencies
and they ha and he's got to invest time
for instance the the the pentagon
needs to devote you know if he wants to
fix bagon
his time and attention is the weapon
system
thing people do what commanders check if
he spends
30 minutes a day on that
front yo his people bring in the
problems and i would do leadership by
anecdote
right there's all this stuff out there
on the internet
and we know that things like like uh
this uh this woman uh uh being canceled
uh for anti-asian
that resonates that's an anecdote it
resonates as a bigger meaning
find the military stuff that has a
bigger meaning there's a chaplain at
elmendorf air force base he's told he
can't say the word jesus great i
secretary of defense i want you chairman
of joint chiefs
i want the joint chief of the air force
i want every single guy down to the
company commander or flight commander in
this guy's chain of command with their
deputies
in my office nine o'clock tomorrow you
will brief me on how you're protecting
this man's
first amendment rights if you uns if
you're unsatisfactory i will relieve you
your deputy will brief me
the next day at 9 00 a.m you do that
one time maybe two they get the message
then i i don't see how uh a democrat
will win 2024
i don't i don't see joe biden as having
nearly the strength to run a second term
oh it's going to be physically
yeah kamala's just so ridiculously
unpopular tulsi gabbard got more
delegates than she did
tulsi got one kamala guys i thought she
would become a republican
i think she probably will i think she'd
fit
yeah it's weird i don't like everything
she's about me neither
but uh but you know what i don't even
like everything i'm about
you know you know jeff van drew he was
the democrat yes yes
jersey yeah new jersey guy he's a he's a
democrat i mean
you look you look at his policy vote for
a union thing the other day
probably the pro actor but he's like the
republicans are more
reasonable that's that's ridiculous how
bad the democrats have become to be
honest
well look we america's got two parties
it's always going to have two parties
because the way the electoral college
exists and you've got to be able to have
50
plus one and i think the democrats
by narrowing and creating this purity
test
are really screwing themselves because
they're going to drive a lot of people
away
and they're not going to have trump to
kick around i mean poor god
pity brian stelter there's a lot of
things to pity that human tuber about
uh but pity tater because
he's got nothing left to talk about okay
i like tucker carlson a lot he's no
substitute for donald trump 24
7. as the raiding show yeah and they're
going to try and run against
donald trump they're already trying in
the recall well this is a this is a
white supremacist trump uh
thing that's why we're recalling uh
newsome get knew some yeah two million
signatures got to be far right huh
yeah all those all those right-wingers
out in california well
yeah i i i'm starting to feel like based
on what we're saying it could be
desantis but hey man look we're years
out so
who knows you know oh we could see
somebody come in that we never expected
uh there are some people who i'm
i'm still trying to figure out why they
would run i like pompeo
but who's the guy who's got pompeo mania
right
ted cruz i i think he's santa says the
fire brilliant yeah
but he you know i mean when i look
like ted cruz has done some good things
but is he presidential
well i gave him i gave him money last
cycle but he lost
last cycle he was doing fairly well but
i just don't see him
it's just that x factor you know what i
mean can he walk up to a guy
in michigan who works on assembly line
and have a conversation that's not
totally awkward now trump
can because trump actually pre he grew
up
with with guys with hard hats you know
guys doing uh
cement work steel work the iron mongers
i mean he he and you see the video see
him going up and talking to the cops
yeah and it's
it you know it's a president and a cop
going how are you doing
but it's not awkward and it's like oh my
gosh
does this guy think i'm a you know does
this guy think i can't do a push-up kind
of
uh vibe it you know trump's comfortable
with who he is and that's i think that
was one of his secrets
you know why they could say how could
how can you like a rich guy like that
because if i was rich i'd do the same
thing right down to the imported model
wife
and the golden toilet and the golden
toilet right
well so you wouldn't want to go on a
golden toilet so uh uh
it's i'd have a golden bidet i'd have a
urinal of gold
he probably does heck yeah so i i think
you know uh
platinum today let's let's take it to
the next level yeah platinum
platinum bidet real expensive that could
actually be my next acapella punk band
platinum bidet yeah there you go make an
album yeah so uh well
let's jump over to super chats and uh
we'll see what the audience has to say
if you haven't already smash
that like button your your smashing of
the like button is is very important to
us
it's the only thing we actually care
about we just sit here all day i'm half
kidding
uh but if you haven't already go to
timcates.com and you can pick up
your very own diamond hands gorilla
t-shirt which is a reference to wall
street bets if you're familiar with the
game stop
stonks thing we created this funny
gorilla he's holding money and it's
about the meme of you know apes together
strong
go to teamcast.com click shop and again
smash that like button
subscribe notification bell share the
podcast let's read some of your super
chats
we got a super chat here and fortunately
youtube cuts off the name of our first
super chat so i can't read it
he says dod ctr here had extremism
training today and spoke up re politic
uh politic
politization of military and concerns of
white extremism push
eight to nine examples of what wrong
looks like were right wing
white uh white including proud boys
stand on principle and always speak up
yeah all right let's see
joe cush says hey tim what do you think
about the recent peaceful violence in
the pacific northwest
violence were they saying things that
were mean no no they weren't engaging in
violence that was
that was uh rehabilitative restorative
resistance
wasn't it at night yeah so it's not
it's not terrorism or insurrection if
it's at knight right
as i understand it and they didn't say
any mean words and mean words are
violence
therefore they were taking physical
action for restorative justice
i see so it was a peaceful restorative
justice night march
got to be specific you know what i mean
you know after a while
people are just getting used to the lies
just being lied to and it just kind of
it's not good so the black blade says i
lose sleep over this question
when the rubber meets the road on the
u.s debt say in 50 to 20 years
when my kids are trying to build a life
will they even earn one dollar working
in the u.s
well i guess to the extent there's good
news
is the entire world economy will
collapse eventually
at this rate uh so
where they can't earn money will be kind
of irrelevant
i think if if it comes to the point
where you can't make a dollar people
stop trading dollars
well then they start trading other
things right like bullets and food
yeah things that will be more valuable
and more directly uh uh
well you know and there there will also
be
well until it's stamped out kind of uh
extracurricular currencies like the
bitcoin
you know their stuff you know what i
always thought was funny when you know a
bitcoin i'm sorry i had to do that yeah
alex jones would be like buy your gold
people you know
you got to buy your gold when telling
people to eat gold
exactly do you know what so i would tell
people this all right let's say you're
walking down the street the apocalypse
right
and you're carrying uh you know like a
big sandwich
and there's a guy on on to your left and
a guy to your right and you're like all
right i got this sandwich let's trade
the guy on your left goes i have a gold
coin
the guy in your right says i have a
bottle of water guess who's going to be
trading for that food
exactly it's not the guy with the gold
coin no water is going to be worth
substantially more than gold
in a crisis situation especially in big
cities yes you could have a big
wheelbarrow full of gold bars and people
are going to be like i can't eat or
drink that dude i'm dying
and they'll be like where's the water at
interestingly i saw this video once
there's apparently like in new york city
a stream that runs under buildings that
you can actually access like
if you jump over a wall yeah it's crazy
yeah it's like and and there was a there
was a dude who's an urban explorer
who talks about how when you go to new
york you see all the city
all these buildings and asphalt but they
actually had to preserve this stream
and so you can actually find it
somewhere i don't know it's crazy story
oh that's freaky
all right let's see tyler watch narowsky
says wow tim i'm very impressed with the
top-notch guests you've had on the show
this week
keep up the great work your show is
fantastic well thank you very much i
mean
look we're we're lucky people want to
come on the show uh it's important that
i be praised
that's right as a los angeles trial
lawyer i have a gigantic ego and it
needs to be
fed and it's good for me too because
when guests talk more
and and and more quickly i can just kind
of relax and be like oh it's like it's
like it's like a break for once you know
schlichter's got this
he's going to talk i'm just going to sit
back and you know let it roll let it let
it
roll on over me it's like a conversation
i love it it's a like it's a chat yeah
it is
all right doobie mcnasty says i'd rather
have pete
says i'd rather have putin than biden
it's painful but true
no i would not rather have putin no no
no putin is a bad
putin's a bad guy yeah and the fact that
the liberals don't like him does not
make him a good guy
putin you know look he's he's a bad he's
a bad
dude who runs bad a group of bad boys
yes he does
and he is he is not nice he's not a
friend of the united states
and if he had more power he would cause
us more damage
uh he doesn't have that much power but
the people the liberals who
won't shut up about him give him more oh
yeah
all right mr rass lion says hey kurt
will you write a novel showing the
splitting of the us from kelly's
perspective
i came into the series from indian
country great guest this week tim
uh yes i'm already reading it number
five crisis
is from his per uh does talk about the
country splitting up
and the next one the split which will be
out in may
uh carries it on and i'm quite happy
with the progress about halfway through
it
i have so much fun writing these books
it is so much
fun to write these novels even though
i'm talking about this horrible stuff
have you played the division the video
game
uh no you should definitely check it out
i'm afraid of video games so
if i start playing video games i may
never stop check out the division i
think you'll like it it's uh it's it's a
few years old at this point it's uh the
first one is about
a bio weapon gets released new york is
it is basically a quarantine zone
so it's like a documentary yes
absolutely
well it's got a governor who keeps
grabbing breasts
well so you you're uh uh you are you're
part of an organization called the
division
which was created under um directive
presidential directive 51 are you
familiar with director 51 i am not
joy to project 51 or i'm sorry i think
it's director 51
george w bush created it and it creates
the ability for the president
to declare an emergency and create a new
continuity of government which creates
like a singular federal authority
all over over all others and it's a
pretty crazy directive
now its legality hasn't been tested but
i think you get a kick out of the game
because you basically play as these
dudes with with guns
and like special reconnaissance tech to
go in and deal with
the the the factions that rise up in
response to a power factor like uh
escape from new york
only this time you're going in ah and
you're trying to deal with
like paramilitary groups that are trying
to take over certain parts of the city
could i have a [ __ ] in back uh mac 10
with a scope on it like
yup yeah you get all sorts of guns and
modifications it's a fun game
it's super fun you go with a group of
like you know three of your friends
and you have to like there's in the
first one you read the lincoln center
and it's take it's been taken right
taken over by like gangs
and it's actually new york city it's
like really you go to like the funny
thing
is woody allen is in it and he has a
gang
of uh young women it's not it
just uh but i'd welcome them it's a
thing it's a it's a mod
i think we should add that up that would
be uh uh mia faro
you can play them off against each other
that's great all right we got you
and and ronan sinatra all right okay
a sense of tangent a sense of muse three
says hey gang
delaware resident here at least once a
week traffic is held up for hours
because of joe biden's traveling
lots of resources and taxpayers time
wasted also do you still have a p.o box
for receiving stuff we do if you go to
timcast.com i think it's in the contact
section
but uh welcome to living near where our
president lives
i'm pretty sure it was like that with
obama when he was in chicago oh he would
come to los angeles and lock it up and i
would just
i remember that i would love it because
it was all the liberals who voted for
him like he said in gridlock with your
president
uh the the funny thing is this guy he he
needs to know that he was gridlocked
this week because they were taking the
dog home
ah very important so he had to make it
for fido
master roosman says you talk about
social media censorship but hardly
mentioned google search result
censorship
since 2016 anti-establishment
information doesn't exist on google
search
i believe we actually did several
segments where i mentioned
my youtube channels my other two were
blacklisted on google search
really yes you have to go to like
duckduckgo or something
yup or directly to type in the url funny
thing is
after i mentioned it on this show the
blacklist
was removed and my channel started to
reappear in google search do you think
that there are
um infiltrators inside google who are
listening to you and who are kind of uh
i i'm taking the word woke to mean
unders you know essentially like are
there like woke people at google who
like spy on the show and trying to get
me in trouble
no no no woke people woke for us woke
who see what we see
oh like red pill i i you could call it
red pill
that's that's the equivalent of woke
woke means they woke up to the realities
of critical race there whatever and
right i just love
saying woke because it just ticks them
off so much you can't say that
well hey i'm doing it b i'm also doing i
i know a lot of people at google
who apparently really like my show
and i've spoken with other major
entertainment companies who have tried
to sign me and pitch deals i've rejected
but they tell me basically google their
big fans
uh it's it's a lukewarm show i keep i
i try i tell people not to swear to
simmer down not to be mean and things
like that
so they like that yeah you're you're
you're mellow milk toast
you're mellow and you i i don't know if
you're milk toast because there's that's
the joke
it's self destruct self-deprecating
there's a lot there's a lot of
going on conserve awoke i think i think
google sees this as
a way to have uh you know look as google
excises
many conservative channels they're gonna
lose a lot of users
so they love it if they can get a
lukewarm centrist show
that conservatives are willing to watch
even if they disagree with it
because youtube can make money then
while getting rid of what conservatives
actually want to watch i don't think
you're
i don't think you're lukewarm i think
you take a very
uh it's becoming a mainstream
conservative view
the mainstream conservatives change it's
no longer a bunch of bow-tied virgins uh
pitching their cruises no look right
right now conservative
is is essentialism and democrat is
constructivism
so whoa that that's what that's what it
is so i took
the eight values test actually i took
the political compass test
i'm a left libertarian i am i am almost
a socialist
but it doesn't ask you questions about
modern culture war issues
it asks you ask you questions about
corporate regulation and international
relations
so sure on those points that mattered
ten years ago that's where i land on the
political compass
on the eight values test i'm mostly an
essentialist but i'm a progressive
progressive and i like a bunch of left
positions
but when it comes to science i believe
that science and objective reality exist
and that's what separates me from the
the woke crowd and
the modern democrats that's probably why
when glenn greenwald said if you think
the proud boys are the seats of power
then you're nuts it's because he's right
there's an objective truth random groups
of you know roving bands of
right wingers is not a threat to the
majority of people in this country
no it objectively is not
and uh
i gotta tell you i love hearing the
people tell me about how they love
science
it's just i think there's a shameless
problem i think we have lost too much
shame
because now they're just lying to your
face
it's like no a man can become a woman
no well freezing weather means global
warming
they've changed definitions yeah they
they do that they they never quite come
out and say yes i am ignoring i'm
ignoring objective reality
but they do and then they kind of like
it but i'll tell you i think the media
is the biggest problem
i understand this is a huge problem well
because the media is choosing to ignore
a bunch of things
yes so i'll give you an example uh brian
stelter wrote another
i think was brian seltzer wrote an
article newsmax ratings collapse or
whatever
newsmax wrote an article cnn's ratings
collapse
but they only mention newsmax in the
newsmax article they mention
newsmax ratings are down cnn ratings are
down hey that's a fuller picture isn't
it
cnn only mentions mentions newsmax and
passively mentions
cable news ratings are down too well i'm
a little biased against cnn since i got
kicked off with don lemon you got kicked
off
on december 22nd 2015 i got kicked off i
was at my last cnn i was
the conservative guy and i i did not i
was not a trump supporter
at that time uh and they called me on
one day
last minute and i did skype from my
office and it was about
uh the the president then candidate
had said uh yeah hillary got schlonged
by uh
obama during the primary and don lemon's
having this fit because he used the word
schlonged
which i i was like okay mild yiddish
vulgarity
i i could not i was i was
reliable talking about why trump was not
a traditional conservative
but i couldn't do it that day i was just
i can't i can't i said don
i care about this so little it would
take stephen hawking to quantify it
and he's like what but that's our
greatest outrage in the history of
outrages
and i said i especially knowing
that this woman you know when we're
talking about this and this is the same
woman who
uh uh enabled her husband
to treat his intern like a humidor oh
there's a lot more than that with the
women have accused bill clinton oh yeah
but i i just said that i did the humidor
thing
and he said you can't say that so i said
it again
because i'll be damned if that little
weirdo is going to tell me
anything and he kicked me off yeah and i
got kicked i got
i i go blind screen goes blank and the
producer goes thank you goodbye click
and it's usually the producer you're
fantastic
you're amazing we'll call you again i
was like huh well that was abrupt
yeah and suddenly my phone starts going
i didn't realize i got cut off
uh it's on youtube it's actually kind of
yeah yeah yeah yeah all right let's read
some more we got the civic nationality
civic nationalist says something that
everyone must learn is people don't
shift to the right but the younger
generation become more left-wing
and that is the cultural shift and tim
made you say
god save the queen well there you go
congratulations
uh yeah i think what happens for a lot
of uh
younger people is that they're
consistently pushed to the left
and i think it's i think there's a lot
of factors there's absolutely
ideological push to make the kids become
more and more leftist
but i think you end up with a generation
you end up with an age group of like
late 20s
that assume young people are further
left
and so these assumptions drive them to
try and market and sell products to kids
that are further and further left but a
better way to put it is probably a
it's a corruption of what they saw when
they were kids when i was a kid
we had family family-friendly messaging
on on kids shows
we had shows where it was like don't be
mean to your neighbors and don't be
racist
and so now these people have grown up
and they've created this corrupted
mutant version of the same thing
that is like nonsensical garbage but
they think it's like that's what i was
told when i was a kid and you're like
what are you are you nuts this show is
insane some of the stuff they show kids
is just
brutal well i i the entertainment
industry is captured by woke that's for
sure but i think there's
look this show your show is an example
of the pushback
you're like the sami's dot the the the
secret
um forbidden information network
in the soviet union i mean you're saying
things that shouldn't be said
you are being you're constantly being
chased by the sensors
uh a lot of other people doing that too
and
people are getting the word i i don't
think that kids are as far left
as the uh uh as
as some people worry uh i think to quote
the who the kids are all right
uh and by the way i love motorhead's
cover of god save the queen
it's really good let me uh let me
singing lead it's beautiful
but i think uh and by the way i think
the death of rock and roll
has been a huge problem for the young
kids because there's no rebel music
now right uh you know i i rock and roll
was always an outlaw brand
now the music is i mean
you know the politicians are hanging out
with the rap artists
it's establishment i guess i'll just
have to make more music videos
yes well yeah loud fast rules man some
punk rock
all right we got we got one for you
though conor o'brien says kurt my
workplace
big four is mandating an anti-racism
training
if i refuse to partake and get fired
will you sue them with me
um well there's a lot of questions there
and i'm not giving anybody legal advice
i'm not a vice lawyer
uh you should you should consult an
employment attorney in your jurisdiction
to find out your rights interestingly
there are many states that uh pass laws
to protect communists
which essentially prevent them from
being biased against people's political
viewpoints
and california is one of them and uh
i bet they never expected it to be used
by conservatives
but i think that is a way to go uh the
look the legal system's not perfect
you're probably gonna lose more cases
than you win
but you know that's how
that's how change through litigation is
made you you you bring cases
and uh donald trump at least in federal
courts
put in a lot of judges who are much more
open hearing this sort of thing
also states look there's a lot of power
in
the states that are not held by woke
liberals
oh yeah and desantis has proven it you
mentioned his uh
censorship stuff there is no reason the
states can't pass laws that's right
freedom of expression and they can make
it very tough
on the tech companies yeah that is one
place we need to do it this is where the
struggle is going to be
and i think you do take them to court
where it's appropriate
right on all right cold water says i was
in the california national guard
infantry in 1992 living in long beach
and activated the same day the riots
broke out
next thing you know i'm running around
compton with an m16 crazy
oh my god he's probably he's probably
three 160 also
what does that mean uh third battalion
160th infantry out of inglewood
there you go uh this is long beach uh
long beach is a little south of there
yeah and i think i think we may have had
a company there i think delta company
was there i don't remember for sure
but hey man colonel wenger
all right dewey mcnasty is back he says
fauci is
he one of the doobie brothers yeah he
was the the the long lost dubby brother
the long-lost people nasty all right he
says fauci is a despotic piece of dog do
rand paul actually grilled him today
it's worth watching
if you haven't love what you do and i'm
jealous of your skating skills now dewey
had to issue a correction because he
spelled skating skills wrong but he says
skating skills effin autocorrect but
thank you for the super chats thanks man
well you've got you got doobies vote all
right i did hear a little of uh
uh of uh uh rand paul today he did a
great job i heard it on yeah yeah uh
and uh yeah that look that's the kind of
thing
we need we've got to keep making our
case
it does change minds eventually and
look we're the common sense guys
and people are going to come around
maybe not today maybe not tomorrow and
it'll probably get worse before it gets
better
but i refute and i'm almost pounding the
table i refuse
to give in to pessimism i refuse to give
up well here's here's an option
omg puppies says the open society
foundation has a 16 billion dollar
endowment from soros
perfect target for a massive wealth tax
well taxi endowments
oh i definitely down with taxing in the
elements on academia
anything that will destroy academia what
is what does will say
seize the endowments i love wheelchairs
sees the endowments
yep yeah yeah that's he started that
right will chamberlain oh yeah will's
woke
i like will but like the right the right
the right one not
he's goodwill he's good i use woke
unless i'm using it ironically
i'm using it you know i guess ironically
dj
madero says please if you want to watch
a great star trek episode watch by the
pale moonlight from ds9
it shows you what a good man will god
he's got an acronym oh yeah
uh that's that's actually one of the
shows it will show you what a good man
will do when he believes the ends
justify the means
quote i can live with it i can live with
it
yeah the s9 is great too that's
uh that's a tougher one as i understand
it's kind of edgier
which one deep state yes i've never
watched it but i it was yeah i
understand it's the edgier one it's not
all like soft and yeah next generation
next next generation was about the like
the philosophical consequences of
technological advancement and meeting
new civilizations
and star trek itself was always kind of
like that meat they would meet a new
civilization that had different cultural
norms and structures
and then like explore it was about it
was about kirk killing romulans
and laying pipe with green alien chips
all right
he was like he was keystone okay that's
how much pipe kirkland yeah
look i'll tell you i'll tell you i
dead serious i i watched star trek rides
i was always on reruns
in the 70s when i was growing up i tried
to model my
some of my some of my leadership stuff
on captain kirk
not all of that no yeah not try but but
but some of the stuff
always always showing confidence oh
always trying to have integrity always
being tactically proficient knowing
knowing your stuff
i mean you could do a lot worse than
being uh james kirk yeah
not the old gym not the movie james kirk
where you can't do a sit-up right
i mean the uh i mean the little tight
green thing
sweaty kirk but the next generation is
the best and they did
i don't know what they're doing now but
i don't you know as much care for it
all right uh svt bill says tim your alex
jones impression is great
lol that's right i think i did it when
alex was here it was funny
hope he says am i in the alex jones
chair yeah you are yeah
oh wow can you smell it
[Laughter]
his heady musk is overwhelming
he was in that chair twice uh op says
hey tim first super chat
would you be interested in having an irl
game have irl gaming events like
tournaments after lockdowns are done
i think it'd be good for building the
brand and building culture
you know what it's a good idea you know
what we should do ian in the venue
we should put floating chairs with tvs
on the ceiling so you're like floating
and playing a video game while like laid
back
you know what i mean i want to make some
360
desks where you can spin around like hey
isn't there like a a body suit that's
attached to like a
a uh some sort of probe in the ground
where you can like do 360 videos with
your eye
yeah there's there's a suit you wear
this is how much i know about video
games
you strap yourself in and you can run in
place in virtual reality
yeah i'm not into anything that involves
being strapped in i'm not like romney
because i think there's an undercurrent
there
[Laughter]
but you know i think there's a vinyl
thing
but i i don't know but uh no that just
seems to
am i i think i've gotten off the points
that sounds like funny all right
well we'll do uh bring me back in we'll
do it we'll do a couple more here
archangel 978 says you must drink every
time we hear about the four lights
lids talks and ian disagrees with tim
also anytime they say smash the like
button
now i gotta stop you right there i think
we've only mentioned the four lights
maybe a total of five times in the past
year and it's come up mostly from
comments
and only twice in the past two days
because literally the episode came on tv
the moment before
we had jack on the show but you know for
saying we smash
when we say smash the like button you
should
drink if you're old enough and
responsible enough
and then smash the like yes or at least
go face down on the like that's right
yeah sea turtle 257 says tim
i am you're loving the names of these
are there like 256 other sea turtles out
there baby
are they are they are they sydney these
are just they usually don't be mcnasty
sea turtles 649. all right
seat journal two correct seven tim i'm a
journalist in the navy
i will be retired this year i would love
to work with you
my first project will be a docu-series
of me traveling different sites
on my motorcycle that sounds pretty cool
uh you can always email jobs at
timcast.com granted it is
just filled to the brim with emails and
we'll go through it when we can but
that's the uh the best way to to get it
you know that i mean i i mean
kurt's input you got a phone
get out there on your bike and do it
that's the beauty of this technological
revolution
i'm looking around at your studio and
you have a very effective studio looks
good
in the big scheme of things it probably
didn't cost that much my brother has a
post production company
20 years ago he bought what was called
an avid system to edit
it costs a hundred thousand dollars see
my iphone
it can edit better yeah you if you want
to be a journalist
get on your bike take your phone go out
there
edit it up put it up and you know
link people who uh do it that's what i
did yeah that's
that's how you do it i mean you know i
mean i
you just build i i start off with andrew
breitbart i wrote one article
now i i get a lot of action over at a
town hall i got my locals
go to my locals page um it's a lot of
fun
and uh you you can do it technology
allows us to do these things and allows
us to get around these gatekeepers
there are no walls they're gatekeeping
walls that fell like the walls around
jericho
all right we got we'll do one more super
chat um
jay ates j h schwalbach says
kurt you just just bought kurt just
about three of your bucks on audible
wife will need to wait a little longer
for the new boobies tim yes i'm a member
but in cali coming to events will be
hard
your books are more important there's a
lot to unpack there
first of all i i mean you know wow
thank you
[Laughter]
congratulations sir well i'm glad you're
keeping us
abreast of your uh reading habits there
you go yes thank you
ladies and gentlemen have you not
smashed the like button we only humbly
ask that you give us those likes and if
you're listening on the podcast on
itunes spotify leave us a good review
and don't forget to subscribe and if you
really really like the show tell all
your friends about it say guys you gotta
listen to the show it's just so good
it's the best show ever
you can follow me on all social media
platforms at tim cast my other youtube
channels are youtube.comtimcast and
youtube.comcastnews this show is live
monday through friday at 8pm so we will
be back tomorrow kurt is there anything
you want to shout out before we hit the
road
thanks for having me uh i hope people go
and check out my books
what are they called uh the first one
people's republic indian country
wildfire collapse and crisis and
they're a lot of fun sounds like it
people seem to be really big fans of
them uh they're
look i i have a lot of fun writing them
and i'm very gratified that people like
them
and of course follow me on twitter go to
my locals page get into my little
community
uh i'm like malice i'm building a little
community what's super gratifying is
i'll go away for a while i'll come back
and people who have posted other things
and they're having discussions
that i don't necessarily be a part of
but i like to jump in on it yeah
that's kind of cool cool all right uh
yeah you can follow me at ian
crossland.net
if you want to check out some of my
stuff as well you're a great canary
stop this you were right stop the
charade it turned out he was right
thanks man and i am sour patch lids on
minds and twitter
we are going to have a members only
exclusive segment coming up at
timcast.com so thanks for hanging out
and we will see you all there
you